hello I could be for everyone and could
good one good morning for myself and
thank you for positive - that gives me
my brief introduction and really nice
introduction and from now on I would
like to introduce you something and some
activity and something that concerns in
our chili sauce came in in t-strap and
today the achievement in outdoor how to
my micro algae or cultivation and other
I am the a Vista our caucus red centre
will not introduce and show you
something that we have done okay next
slide please
okay the scope of the talking today is
we are and and why and how we work and
what we have and the thing that will try
to deliver it and next slide please
and we are Thailand issue of scientific
and technology research we have penny
location we try to initiate and very
nice on the research I will discover it
in dushanyi and we already have our
scattered research by Sophia and also we
serve for industrial we have the
industrial metrology and tasting so we
Center in the South Bangkok
so we're the center of the picture
yeah and we are working under the
Ministry of Science and I am belong to
the biocide apartment okay so okay
the twister back down we have to be in
1963 we are nonprofit States enterprise
under the Misty off side and we initiate
the conduct and Andy to provide as
anti-soviet for us
and especially we are try to do indicate
ion D on freshwater microalgae from
upstream to downstream okay food slide I
think the next slide with atmospheric
co2 in the bottom right the next time
and then one more slide please I'm good
next one and the next one please
so certainly for everyone there we will
post these slides on our website so
you'll be able to see the original
slides within a day or two tied to state
that by ebook I think we are the first
human Chi that lives under 400 ppm
coming outside speakers and we have the
trouble about the unstable earth and
many people tried to do on the linear
energy in many ways and however we sat
sick some enough subsist on and on the G
of 2015 Julian has run some sustainable
development goal that we adopt to our
aim of our research in art initiative in
Teesta also can I ask you a more
detailed question about this global
trends yeah the bottom right yeah this
is really how tester sees the trims in
the oil and gas industry right yes yes
okay next slide
yes and Dow to me just hop down to the
least you know I mean your Southeast
Asian and and Thailand twin Thailand
Thai to adopt do
policy of the alternative energy
development we launched the we call a
ADP alternative energy development plan
that launched last year and will be
further on 2036 we we had aim we will
try to use 30% of renewable energy
within next 15 years and along with the
economic trend we need to emphasize the
Bioeconomy the creative economy digital
economy and social economy also and
however under the policy and the economy
a trend we have to find proper
technology to aim to reach that point
and piston is one of the research
institute at try to utilize the
technology of audi technologies okay
thank you
so slide next slide and what can the LT
technology can do for for Thailand or
for sustainable by oak economy in
Thailand the government has launched the
new engine of the cloud we call tin
socket Industrial that to push our
economic infertile
we aim the industry of cluster or bio
chemicals and down to the biochemical I
think alkyl has the most potential to
have the huge value chain from the seeds
of the algae and choose the customer
product and on the right hand are
destroyed we try to show some product
some innovation of our technology just
we can produce the protein from the
aunty that cost is allowed for off for
3,000 but
you know we can produce to pick in from
the artist especially Thailand Oh Akiko
panty we don't have any active compound
it is surprisingly arty can make you
many active combat as a crow active
compound funky side out in set aside our
hobbies Fido or even panel speculators
so doctor Sarasota is that why sister
decided to put so much emphasis into
algae related research yeah because
there are many applications yes thank
you
so next slide next slide and this slide
we try to show what we have we have fun
adding adding adding allowed 8 million
USD and because we are the biggest algae
culture collection in Thailand we have
more than 1000
artists and in our collection we have
our own research we have our
biotechnology and we have our
engineering team in the middle of this
picture you can see our more arrows but
it's become real because in the mid-to
in this year we will move to work in our
new building that this beauty aim to be
an open research center if you do
something about LT you can come here and
we can talk together we can discuss and
we can share something because
government already funding some
infrastructure we need any guy who
interested in RT and we can do the
research to cater and the picture on the
approach hand we have our facility of
the outdoor Westway cultivation to scale
it around 400 cubic meters so actually
the racetrack our facility
upper I can't have this slide and it's
very impressive that you will have the
algae being grown and being a speed
evaluated and measured in in this
facility
yeah but I noticed that in some open air
facility yeah is that a difficulty that
make it difficult to keep the algae pure
yes by this by this way it has pro and
con and because the event is we can
cultivate the ulti at the local lower
cost but we had to try to collect the
algae that's suitable to the open air
but but but we can before we have used
on our culture collections we can skin I
was worshipping state in the outdoor the
performance it quite based you know and
that why we easy has already know her
from about the contamination from from
others
okay okay right next slide next slide
this is our past how to purchase their
past activity of tasks successfully we
start our culture collection in 1995 and
we already launched our tech transfer
and services to the industrial to the
companies during 2004 due to to 2010 and
week in the big funding budget for from
the wicked or companies in Thailand we
hope it PCT are to be some clue that
scoop big house think it is to be a new
technology of participation 400 other
product okay since 2012 weekend the
budget for making some offices of center
as I told you
and we during the year of 2015 or last
year we expand our facility to observe
or to prepare for marine algae also and
the our ultimate goal we try to push up
or try to invent come or say innovation
for industrial okay I think this is
important because it shows that history
is not only doing more or less basic
research but is also doing technology
transfer to really make sure that the
output can be used by industry yes okay
[Music]
how we are the innovation on the tech
generation but if I say a generation I
mean by all four deities of course if we
play our strategy pass through our
excellent centers we have used all of
the alcohol in short we are achieving
election on every day we have our
biotechnology team that had to invent or
try to research many methodology to
improve the quality of OT in term of a
cloth or production and we have our own
engineering team whooping our dream come
true because I'm a noble dignity
I cannot imagine that we have our nice
team our engineering and we also have
any cocaine across the world we have our
nice team in Thailand that why we can
produce such a nice research in in our
delicious in Tunisia
can you tell me a little more on the
bottom layers of multidisciplinary
collaboration yes what is this think
algae program what is the algae problem
they are cheap program is the clue of
people from national in stale from the
top diversity in Thailand try to get
together this
action sharing funding to research in
the innovation of this technology
okay next slide
yes this is the Andy in third generation
biofuel
this means we collect or we select the
best stay in that can perform out of it
quite well and I think we caught the
very best faster instance in the world
and the our stay and obtain or 30 or 40
percent of dry weight and after that we
try to optimize the best conditions in
terms of cost of cultivation in outdoor
scale and we develop the pyrosphere
production from best culture to
automatically turn on last scale and of
course after we got the fruit oil we
sent to the PCT countries can purify or
do something about a clue I of course we
got some biotech and I think in I'm not
sure in the near future or not but I
certainly true us we will fight the
plane the energy by biotech from algae
in the future
so if I've got the process correct yeah
you select an algae strain grow it yeah
then you dry it not got dry not dry the
house is just removed from the water
that it and then from that you do batch
processing essentially refining oil and
the algae yes okay so and then there are
various possible possibilities for
output we'll talk about those in a
minute yeah
next slide yes yes this is our how to
say I'm not sure I can say it's just
innovation or not but we try hard to
make nice
is not captain picture it's a little one
interest we come we try to come at 10
porn that you spawn contain allow 20
tonne of cultivation we call party
request way pond we connect a spawn dead
either pipeline and from we clone the
auntie at the first porn and let it out
slowly down at the bottom this is the
first one okay and this is a foot the
algae we call continuous ii ii ii pond
light the slow water speed and the algae
clone day by the unto the seven day at
the 7th pawn and then we the algae
accumulate the maximum of the oil
content in the cell we remove or we be
virtually not rowdy and weekly claim
water to cultivate RT again and we send
the algae slurry or artists watch to the
cell disruption system that we have
repent to breaking the sale because
there is containing inside and then send
to the extraction process and what is
the ultimate goal of these plant this
plant can reclaim water again and again
you don't throw the water or carried off
water after we dewatering the deal
importer can reclaim and healthy we had
algae again we we calculate by ion
chromatography and some computer poker
and adding the absorb nutrients that are
t used to produce all mass that why this
process can produce the oil continously
and produce the biomass continuously so
you say each one of the tracks
Twitty
yes so that means that if it takes about
a week in each of the track No one day
one day one day okay so you can produce
our 20 tonnes per week yeah okay okay
yeah that's pretty good
that's like yes and this is some data of
our cloud our plant and I I do not live
in the detail but from our preliminary
data we can't cane the top right props
per day we can make we can't conclude I
allow 44 kilo canvas and we have the web
with F over allow 20 allowed to a team
that can be produced some fertilizer or
something stock or so after we removed
the hexane already so the leftovers can
be used for fertilizers I have used for
other purposes yes yes okay yes no next
after the stage of the cultivation we
can some some data and we can some
things some weak point that we have to
develop because we cultivate in open air
we facing some coffee earlier sometime
please have to do more about a heavy
inoculum that why the first we try to it
went more for inoculum and we try to
create some news open let's weigh upon
by job fabric oddly it is a blue pond
that can maintain that appears in some
case if you need to maintain the pH of
cultivation
also in neither technology we call up 14
a cultivation system because I didn't if
you are the object ID in the
conventionally cultivation we cultivate
the algae only 0.5 meter or 50
centimeter depth or Atty to cultivate
1.2 melody but we try because if we
succeed we can multiply the biomass and
in the same area maybe treat her more
but we have to we have to come over the
engineering technology because we need
to bring the walk the algae to the light
that righty I will explain more in the
next slide and we challenge the new
state that has really high performance
or mortal state or extraction system and
of course we try to solve the energy
consumption by we install the polar
protic or solar cell in our control room
and this energy will be utilized as a
bubble or maintain the cultivation of
the algae at night or during the daytime
in laboratories ok so I want to point
out that the economics of this kind of
algae production are very important
that's one reason it almost has to be
open air yeah
because even even you know if it had to
be within a enclosed environment there's
no way commercially you could do this in
a cost-effective way
yes and you know the same thing is how
much you can grow per cubic meter by
doing this at a 1.2 meter depth your ma
you're able to do much more production
than other people would yeah kind of
with a much shallower ya pond or
whatever yes yes because I have seen
these huge algae ponds that are only
about 30 centimeters yes but
nucleus even scientifically am and
priced right ultimately it won't be
commercial the photovoltaic you're using
to regulate temperature mostly yes okay
and that's so that at night the
temperature does not drop known under
diamonds it to keep it cool during the
day what's the regulation you're using
the solar energy to to talk to bubbling
that algae cultivation we do not control
the temperature of the calculation of
the out at all
okay this is keeping the motion yeah yes
sir you got it okay thank you
next slide it's like this is your flow
yeah this is up flow because I think if
we need to cultivate Chandra LT more
deeply in more deeply in porn we have to
study the first one tries to solve in
biology hallway that means you need to
engineer and bring the algae or change
out from inside to have the fast or high
efficiently for that for like caching
but if you don't do that I select the
way of internal links off because if we
do with if we saw this problem by the
engineering strategy I may have many
people get together to help me in this
case we develop with some companies to
to make the low consumption energy pump
that can pump the algae I add a layer of
30 10 for hours and consume a little bit
of energy consumption and I on the right
top which are the picture of
conversation of the house this is simple
the system would to the help a twister
okay and this is how our system work we
have the pipe life for algae into the
pan and during the day time the algae
flow and in the double layer of the pond
and from this is my hand and
concentration of the Archaea tea I did
it quite high if you working with RTG we
really like that it's a really high
concentration and why we do what I did
the lesson be high when the algae clone
an optical density is allow 0.5 the
light penetration is quite hard that why
we try to move the algae out of the porn
to expose to the sunlight in the thin
layers of the Dublin astonished porn
okay so you just put your hand down into
the wall offering scoop yeah yeah I'm
curious
at this point do you work with one
strain of algae typically for several
weeks or several months yeah how often
do you have to totally clean up the
entire system and switch to a new type
of algae no the best thing that can can
and that's done in the laboratory before
you get out here at grow no no I want
strategy we need to go outdoor we send
everything out and you see like the
silver ball don't bury into the earth to
traditional yeah that's why that make
sure fun we tow it away it can happy but
like a lot of research and development
facilities if you're using different
kinds of algae yeah it must be really
hard to clean this up and
between one yeah yeah yeah okay good
thank you next one looks like is it
system we try to lose the past acute
because we aim to accelerate the algae
biomass by the intention of the carbon
dioxide by injection the cameras are in
such system we can capture or we can for
us the common oxide you saw in the
liquid media along the way of the open
point right that was but but it's not
enough Rockwell at this time because
we're facing with the battleframe occur
don't you doing during the exclaiming
but I think it quite knife or for a
prior to human oxide okay okay
next this is just a picture to show
everyone how this system works okay okay
next slide
and so we through the mode of the
collaboration we not we are not only for
basic research we collaboration we do
the contact research with company also
with national and internationally in
Thailand we do atlases with a PTT group
the biggest Ottoman in Thailand to
develop the power outage I and we're
dealing with your Mali cook the biggest
juice company because why did it
just how many conservative because they
have with water treatment plants and
they need to utilize that wastewater to
become some fittings or their fitting
stock so seed stock or chemical
production or for food for animals for
animals okay fine and in epidemic Louise
horrible a bit major University tied to
develop the too often
and metabolic engineer that can engineer
the native stain of the algae I think
everyone knows the green algae it quite
hard to engineer because it cannot
accept the foreign DNA into the gas
shale and we also collaborate with the
Denso company in Japan so it's the part
of the tech companies yeah then so is
one of the biggest parts and systems
suppliers to Toyota yes so this is what
we do for PTT but I can I cannot say I
cannot say this must be hard this is
some investigative we try to emphasize
something PTT try to see the high value
product along LG technology also and of
course decide to invent some complex
eyes injection technology that can be
utilized the Commodores I Fon from the
petroleum industry and they believe in
the cultivation technique that we try to
to triggering forums
well the algae actually consume a lot of
co2 this is just our collaboration if we
when we work with dancers and so to try
to encourage actual to work and they try
to do everything that make this
technology hopefully and all of them
already resistant I am very proud and
really pressure pressure for for
pressure means straight
I mean I I try to show you how much I
stress many company many people try to
do more and keep going on algae
technology for even other bio food out
and in a company that I drew Kanaly I
was going to ask you about you Tulane
because there they were a startup
company I knew their founder when he was
a student came to Stanford for an
entrepreneurship summit yeah and they
recently went public in Japan yeah and
have really had a difficult time but so
are they interested in your work are
they cooperating once they come ladies
they see everything and maybe someday in
the future okay okay like mr. Keshe
company is ready huge industry for a big
company right yes and they are they do
the same or do the similar on the last
two slide it's like I try to emphasize
of course we try to the Audi to
industrial and you see the power past
early we turn for the technology to some
company to make the bio fertilizer the
leaping fertilizer believing auntie that
can fix today from the air into the car
out and some soil conditioner the algae
that can produce the polysaccharide keep
moisture content in in the
joy and of course maybe a hopefully the
professor - you come in comfort histah
in next year I will show you some other
innovation about edible no stop
try to give it up yeah I call the algae
how ears okay I'll keep our just tiny
algae Bob this is the man-made algae
digit technology you cannot party in
Indonesia okay
please hi to push some innovation for
surf the techno
okay no fault in the police yeah and in
the past we have estimate the tide
industrial standard for for really
system emotion pain because in Thailand
we are the multi or the moisture across
the country every pain we are facing
without you punitive you know this
edible food would be very high protein
what would be the advantages yeah okay
and also if you're growing it as part of
another process it's rather efficient
yes okay are these things going to be
sweet or seem like jelly ball the proof
but it fulfill with a protein and ready
naturally you know okay great
thank you so next website I mean I think
this is maybe the last line of my
presentation this teacher what our idea
about the technology and clopidogrel you
seen of course along of my presentation
which I try to show you we have three
more we have three I think more
important factor the first one we have
our only sausage and we keep going to
collect more LT we have the active
outside
technically search we have the outer
cultivation technology that tree effect
can make you more things more invention
on technology on left-hand side we try
to make super fertilizer I mean next
generation biofuel is the fertilizer
that not only fit the nitrogen from the
air but also provide some political I
keep the soy more moisture and in in the
same way they can give some plant
hormone our regulators along that
fertilizer and if you share something
like this by use the combination of the
out-of-state I think we can gain super
fertilizer that environmental friendly
or something okay
this is the left hand side and right
hand side because of Thailand Iraqi
cultural based country we focus you have
the next generation of a copy a copy
means do not ordinarily first stop for
our for the fish it deliver some
functional protein the pigment for color
lingered
the pigment in the fish and they have to
promote emotional city of the fish and
get fish more okay this is just this is
the next focus of our research center in
in term of bio fertilizer and a half
stop for soap salon economy so cell
since graduate uh is is this pretty much
your presentation is this the last one
yes so while we move take the slides off
and and show our picture it again I
think that it would be useful let me ask
couple of question with regard to who
who your competitors are who are who are
other other nations that are doing the
same kind of research we in Thailand be
almost no competitors ah no one needs to
compete with Batista maybe maybe I and
sister is obviously attracting
international attention because of this
research
you know when with the big companies
like then so I want to come to you and
find out what you're doing yeah that
also means that you've established kind
of an international expertise center of
expertise in this yeah I'm curious about
the technology transfer out so from this
stage what would the next step be
would you have plants small-scale plants
in different parts of Thailand or what
would they do
because now if you need to invest in
these technology you need to consider
about the location first right right
that that why I think that the next step
may be the company try to invest some
plant in Thailand and when you say
locations what kind of location does it
need to be three things you need
sunlight that means the location along
the tropical zone ok avakov okay we need
to have a little bit or more much enough
of waters in a second and the third is
if that location
akiko so country that should be nice big
hog fertilizer is really nice for supply
the new into the algae right mm-hmm
do you have people at tester who are
going out into the forests and out into
the jungle and trying to find new algae
of course okay so that is part of the
research yeah if you need to go this is
the way we maintain our potential we
always call it we always seeking the new
thing India to a local agent okay and
with regard to what happens after you
take the algae out of the racetrack
plant okay you have a series of
basically processing equipment inside
Pistor that you're actually making
biodiesel and biofuel of various sorts
mm-hmm are you you're actually doing all
the process out to the end product yeah
and how do you see which products are
important are you looking at mostly jet
or are you looking at diesel for trucks
or what do you think is driving
applications the the diving application
it should be
yeah I think I think I agree with youth
partly because we're seeing more
electric vehicles yeah yeah yeah
although here in Thailand one of the
things I've noticed are trucks that have
lots of canisters of compressed natural
gas yeah
so these are big trucks and you know
they have a rack of 16 to 20 big natural
gas yes - yeah they look nice but they
look impressive but I'm curious if this
would be cost-competitive
for a truck you know in trucking to have
to buy diesel we have to fly high yeah
okay
so basic question about biofuel mm-hmm
first generation was based on sugars
yeah especially from corn sugar that was
done a lot in Brazil mm-hmm what was
really the second generation of biofuel
if algae is the third generation yeah
what's in between can be if they don't
ignore cellulose technology okay and of
course that's been very difficult to
make cost-effective yeah I think one of
the issues is the energy required to
produce the biofuel versus the energy
that you get from the bio yeah yeah
does algae stand up well in terms of you
know if you've got natural sources of
energy to make the algae grow it not so
there now not so well yeah but we have
to research more that why we need to do
something along with the bio fuel from
algae yeah we need to have seek more
core process and through production and
in our next you know the next month we
try to invent we try to affect the look
first and then you got your oil you need
to extract the protein and pigment
before right and with that and let the
oil production just a by-product okay I
see so other products would be the main
product and then the fuel would be the
byproduct okay again efficiency Briana
what it returns the computer around and
let's look at people in the audience and
open the floor to questions what do we
have for questions anybody Briana do to
make sure that you recognize the people
are asking hello
I'm interested I'm okay I'm interested
in how you deeply use I'm interested in
how you deal with weather variation from
drought to monsoons in terms of algae
production okay
so the question is how you deal with
variation in the weather between the dry
season and the wet season is the best
thing that that because I think we
cannot control the weather condition we
try to pay more and working hard for the
state selection just saying that can
tolerate all wetter or all year round
that that that good I wish I kill you
for for 40 so the key is really the
straining of algae yeah that you have
something that can deal with either
weather pattern geisha okay and I guess
those algae exist are you doing magnetic
and engineering of the algae not so much
because they have to - we have the
optical of their genetics transfers but
it may still misty you keep going on
this before some someday in your future
if you cannot emphasize or cannot
production out dog as well reveal more
genetic okay okay but of course that
involves an entire new set of safety
standards and of course we have the the
cross system for taste good okay great
next question yes the question is are
you aware of there's a laboratory in
China in Shenzhen they're doing the same
thing cultivated algae in trying to get
oil out of the algae so Bevin can I ask
you a little bit more about this
laboratory in Shenzhen is a university
laboratory or an independent government
lab
or or accompany laboratory it's I think
is up both and I've I only contact them
a few years ago and they said is very
difficult to get the oil out from the
algae the amount of energy put into it
it's not even worse the oil come out
yeah yes so first of all about this
group in ginger do you know even on this
technology and try to keep move on this
research but I think the theoretical
China in a suitable for colonial tea
even in the Sultan of China also so it's
too cold in winter
yeah I think to call okay and what about
this comment from the professor in China
that it's too difficult to get the oil
from the algae it's not too difficult to
get the oil from the algae but it's
depending on the cost and your
technology to to accept them and also
possibly on the strain of the algae yes
you much you have your own nicely stem
yes but what kind of protection can you
make for the this sort of process do you
get a patent on the particular strain of
algae or is it all on the production
what would be intellectual property for
this is it mostly the production
technique or is it the algae it's all
but okay I can tell we have our owned
our team self and the production to save
us all
okay we have mean when our technology
that can extract oil without drying the
biomass we have the wet extraction
technology okay so good Bevin did you
have a follow-up or okay right the one
years I saw in his a one of his chart
has the efficiency of getting an oil and
as well as the cost of the oil in one of
his chart so where where is he
okay this chart and I I took down our
slides from here so let me go back and
find it this was one of the earlier
slides yes probably yes at the very
introduction yes oops was this it or was
it hold on just a second okay now this
is the pink algae project I think we
need to go further back
yeah I'm can you find the this lot
because we're tester is in the current
technology roadmap is is the good
question right so it's probably this one
that has sister a EC at the top of the
slide and down at the bottom right you
have the lab scale you know where oil
production yield and cost yes so that
the right hand side increases and the
left hand side decreases the or the
yield improves so on that scale where is
sister right now yes near the bottom
yeah yeah okay and is that close to the
goal or do you want the the goal to be a
lot needs to be up at the top right this
is this is our goal okay plan we now we
can decrease the production cost of the
oil I think actually in the laboratory
you need allow 20,000 baht per liter of
oil but after we researched maybe two
years we can decrease the price of the
oil okay into 1000 and 800 but I mean I
didn't have decrease in the cross and
production cost and gajeel we can
promote the deal a 20% of our
acceleration at lab scale up to thirty
and forty percent in the demonstration
plant okay the quality of the oil that
you produce is the pain it depend
meaning it can be high quality or it can
be not so high quality okay alright good
thank you
I have a question I have a question in
the back
coming around thank you I had of course
model loebsack
I had a question about you had a slide
in there about how you were making the
Gnostic balls that algae edible Gnostic
balls could you speak a bit to how those
are like how you make them uniquely from
like anyone else any other companies I
couldn't quite get all of your questions
this is the the foodstuff that's being
made right yeah yes how do you know your
question is basically what competitor it
has or what the edible non stop all
right mm-hmm how do you make that yeah
how do you I guess have a competitive
edge and making that okay how do you
make it competitive will this be in the
supermarket's next week I cannot tell
you how how can I make innovation you
know we have our nice table - this is
technology for perform a t-bone or stop
I can buy you can buy for me not you do
not try to do it I see do you think that
this will be something that will
eventually be either licensed out to a
company to Mankato retail yes of course
and between here and there
I guess the quality the safety of the
food production will be very important
yes okay okay excellent okay thank you
interesting question next question
another question if that's okay
referring to it to the oils that you're
producing do you know which what's like
the chemical composition of those are
those like fatty acids or like fatty
acid methyl esters friends like the
biofuel
the oils that are produced are they
fatty acids or what is it what is the
nature of the oil itself and this is not
necessarily fuel this is so would this
be similar it is something like olive
oil or would it be yeah it is a mixing
of the fatty acid esters right
uh-huh okay does that answer your
question specifically for I that's the
fuel like which which Orioles would use
for fuel like what's the chemical
composition of those those oils the is a
middle chain fatty acid the C between 16
and 18 I I can tell you that I can do I
can say okay okay alright so the oil is
obviously a hydrocarbon yes and can you
say whether it has lots of carbon in it
and so would have a lot of co2 generated
or will it be relatively okay yeah okay
all right great well we'll leave that at
this thanks for your question next
question it seems to me that the most
the difficulty of having generating oil
from LT is the price competition when
the oil price goes down then almost
every project stops yeah so the one of
the problems with this kind of research
really has been yes the price of oil yes
yes but I think our decided arity we if
we cannot go further with oil we can
submit all of our plan to produce 14
pigmen we just switch our stain depend
on the purposes of of of the
production or after product if I need to
produce the high protein light spirulina
I can change too spidery not into our
system or if you need to do as I sent in
our the Pikmin we just reach the state
because all the technology can do
together sit water
dewatering say breaking or instructional
so at a commercial scale that's very
interesting
what you do it be changed the
application yeah change the stress yes
we decide a system that durability time
we need to switch we can't change so I
think a lot of biofuel research research
in the United States sort of disappeared
along with the advent of shale oil ok ok
but so far Thailand has continued to
sustain because it I think is the cycle
right maybe yeah it's become if I think
it's not political
that's a dad yeah yeah but making sure
that you keep a research program going
despite changes in politics sometimes
it's harder than dealing with changes in
weather
okay other questions okay so a voce LJ
also grow in an unimproved pond could
run imagine a cottage industry that
everybody has a pond in his backyard and
filters out Graciela they are and
filters em out or does it always require
this enormous capital investors I'm
having a picking up your question I'm
having a hard time understanding it will
you okay again a little bit slower okay
I think we've got some trouble with the
audio on okay so bhutya LJ also grow
perhaps at less efficiency in unimproved
ponds so that you could imagine a
cottage industry that people have a pond
in their backyard and filter out the
algae growing there without this great
capital investment which you obviously
have if I'm understanding your question
correctly this would be whether this is
going to be a very distributed
production industry with lots of very
small suppliers like individual farmers
mm-hmm or or would it be something that
you would have giant algae plants that
will be the the most effective way of
producing is that your question yeah
yeah that's something okay yeah I I
think in case of biofuel oil it need to
invest form the biggest fund bigger
companies but in case of fertilizers and
a half-ish we can distribute in a small
investor okay that's actually very
interesting because it would enable
farmers to be much more independent
mm-hmm but sure enough for fuel
production economy of scale and
efficiency of scale is a is a big factor
yeah did that get your question yes the
same thing is continuing in this vein if
you get the perfect LJ and they escape
into a polluted water base will they
start algae blooms everywhere else in
the waterways of Thailand
Breanna would you try restating the
question I really care if algae escapes
from these ponds and ends up somewhere
else in Thailand what could happen okay
what happens is the algae escapes okay
weren't you out you escaped from our
point died in the environment okay
so it really needs to be sustained in
the nature taken care by one of us do
you have strains that are highly toxic
do you have to worry about that with
toxicity yeah we don't work with very
that that's clarified they're really
toxic okay okay so you're not working
with yeah okay excellent thank you
mm-hm question thanks very much I'm
sorry we're having a little trouble with
our audio side so while we're looking
for other questions let me ask kind of
what's next for testers research you've
been scaling up this production are you
do you think that will be the main focus
is scaling up to commercial size now or
will the next step in this really be
looking for new strains of algae or
improving the processing after the algae
is grown and you have all kinds of
things that you can do yeah the first
thing we need to give more for the
processing we need to give more
invention for pricing for testing for
another product any any care products
and of course seeking the artist and is
our duty we always call like we love to
collect the algae unless we need to
because I think that the solar
atmosphere is quite nice for algae
growing we need to eat more excellent
algae okay do you see another
alternative for this kind of is are
there any alternatives to algae in
regard to the versatility in regard to
you know both for food production as
well as fuel production we we hope in
some day we can use the RT as a platform
of the hormone production
okayhow more product and some concern to
the to the medicine and far away from
from from the food we we taught us a bit
the platform that can you utilize our
GED
medical fact early or vaccine or
something so let me just say a couple of
words because Thailand is in an unusual
position in regard to research like this
the country can't afford to fund just
huge amounts of basic research they
really have to make choices early about
what kind of technology roadmaps
technology directions will be
appropriate for the country's economy
what will be the best for the country's
economy and it's exciting to me to see
so much work being done in biological
products and processes without the
extremely expensive kind of approaches
that you see in other countries so that
from the very beginning
Pistor has really looked at the economy
of production and has looked at these
real practical problems about how would
you ever bring this out in the real
world right yes so I'm really glad that
we could feature your research today for
series hot pocket and you know do we
have other questions if not I think we
can go ahead and call him into this
session I almost forgot I want to say
thanks to the miner foundation for
providing us with some so financial
support of this series and we hope that
you will stay outside and network and
meet each other we'll talk here in the
conference room here for a little bit
longer and do our own networking are
there other questions
Rhian to anyone else I have back back I
have one more question and it's related
so if you could is there any I guess
problem that you think that
biotechnology could solve to reduce your
operating costs
you know how could biotechnology
approaches thought to solve helped to
improve that reduce the costs of
operations I do engineering i I think it
can but we can not use this energy alone
we have to integrate from the O'Reilly
field
we need to engineer we need engineering
we need any kind of technology that can
be so I think by biotechnology is very
excellent technology but we cannot stand
alone to solve that hyper right
have you explored any kind of new
enzymes to process the algae into oil
and into fuel not good yeah okay okay
because I think that there is some work
in that but that's also extremely
expensive yes okay mega bleep that's you
back in the back I think you had a
question
this is Walter now what is the what is
the most critical scientific problem
that you're facing they would have you
to move forward so what's the biggest
scientific problem that's a barrier to
moving forward a challenge and moving
forward is how to maintain the accuracy
of the floor of the cloud of the outside
do you know I think in the way of growth
algae cultivation concentration it quite
low compared to other micro organism if
you can cultivate algae at three
computers in in in two or three day I
call you God this is a little barrier we
need to develop the high-density
cultivation of the algae biomass
production
because if you don't have an accurate
flow the algae dies what happens yeah
okay that's yeah that's sort of what I
thought you know okay
that's a great question - is there other
questions from the floor I don't see any
hands going up I think that might be all
okay great then I want to thank everyone
for coming
if you would please join me in thanking
dr. Serizawa for a very interesting
process
you